bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans
savourgarde sur LCP au sommaire ce soir
notre grand témoin Jean-Louis bourlange
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes président de
la commission des affaires étrangères à
l'Assemblée nationale votre discours sur
la situation au Proche Orient la semaine
dernière à l'assemblée a été très
remarqué et on va s'interroger avec vous
justement comment éviter un embrasement
général au Proche Orient que pèse
aujourd'hui la diplomatie française dans
la région et plus globalement dans le
monde dans l'actualité également ce soir
la constitutionnalisation de l'IVG en
France Emmanuel Macron veut faire
aboutir la procédure dès 2024 ce serait
une première mondiale mais ce droit
est-il menacé dans notre pays et faut-il
voir dans sa constitutionnalisation une
protection absolue et irréversible de
tout cela on débat avec nos invités dans
un instant enfin ne ratez pas nos
affranchis ce soir nous serons avec
Richard verli et Cécilia gabizon ainsi
qu'elsam moningava pour la chronique
Bourbon Express voilà pour le sommaire
c'est parti pour ça vous
[Musique]
regarde les chiffres ont été publiés
hier 234000 IVG ont été pratiqué en
France l'an dernier c'est un plus haut
depuis
1990 il faut savoir qu'en France une
femme sur trois environ recourt à l'IVG
une fois dans sa vie alors quand on voit
ces chiffres on peut s'interroger
pourquoi vouloir constitutionnaliser ce
droit aujourd'hui pour en débattre nous
accueillons sur ce plateau Marie-Pierre
rixin bonsoir vous êtes député
Renaissance vous avez présidé la
délégation au droits des femmes de
l'Assemblée nationale pendant 5 ans et
vous êtes membr aujourd'hui du Haut
Conseil à l'égalité entre les femmes et
les hommes Mathilde Panau bonsoir vous
présidez le le groupe la France
insoumise à l'Assemblée nationale
bonsoir et vous avvez présenté une
proposition de loi qui visait à
constitutionnaliser le droit à l'vgé qui
a été adopté en première lecture à
l'Assemblée et au Sénat on va en
discuter évidemment Sarah Durocher
bonsoir vous êtes président du planning
familial et vous êtes membre également
du Haut Conseil à l'égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes et puis Benjamin
Morel bonsoir vous êtes docteur en
sciences politiques et maître de
conférence en droit public à Paris de
Assas et on compte sur vous pour nous
éclairer justement sur les subtilités du
droit constitutionnel et puis bien sûr
notre grand témoin Jean-Louis bourlange
vous intervenez dans ce débat quand vous
le souhaitez mais pour commencer le
chrono de Blacko Stéphane blackowski
nous
rejoint bonsoir Stéphane bonsoir Clément
bonsoir à toutes et tous alors pour
commencer bah rappelons déjà ce qui
s'est passé aux États-Unis à la fin juin
2022 vous voyez ça c'était la couverture
de Libé le dessin de coco le jour la
Cour suprême euh a décidé de mettre fin
au droit à l'avortement laissant libre
chaque état de décider s'il pouvait
interdire l'IVG et de fait aujourd'hui
il y a une vingtaine d'État aux
États-Unis qui interdisent ou qui
restreignent le droit à l'avortement et
bien en France au même moment donc fin
juin 2022 nous venions d'élire une
nouvelle assemblée et la première à
avoir réagi cette aurore Bergé qui était
à l'époque présidente du groupe
prenaissance elle a déposé une
proposition de loi constitutionnelle
pour inscrire le droit à l'avortement
dans la Constitution alors sur ce coup a
un peu pris de vitesse Mathilde Panau
qui elle a déposé sa proposition de loi
une semaine plus tard enfin soyeons
honnête tentons d'être honnête c'est
jamais facile mais et les filles
militaient depuis longtemps pour
inscrire l'avortement dans la
Constitution ce qui n'était pas le cas
de la majorité la preuve en 2018
justement quand les fi proposaient
d'inscrire l'avortement dans la
Constitution la majorité vous voyez pas
trop l'intérêt on écoute ilelle Bron
Pivet à mon sens il est nul besoin de
brandir des peurs relative à ce qui se
passe dans d'autres pays pour estimer
que ces droits seraient menacés dans le
nôtre ça n'est absolument pas le cas
aujourd'hui rien ne vous permet de
l'affirmer merci mais enfin inutile de
raviver de vieilles querelles
politiciennes au fait mieux souligner ce
qui arrive rarement c'est pour une fois
la majorité et les filles sont à peu
près d'accord regardez finalement c'est
la proposition de loi et les filles qui
a été examiné en premier elle a été
votée avec les lois de la majorité
d'autant plus facilement que Aurore
berger de son côté avait retiré sa
proposition lo s'était rallié à LFI donc
une belle victoire pour LFI pour ce
qu'on appelait la nupè à l'époque
souvenez-vous mais aussi pour les
féministes c'est pour ça qu'on avait
chanté donc souvenez-vous petite chanson
[Musique]
alors pour ceux qui nent pas reconnu
j'en faisais partie ce matin c'est
debout les femmes l'hymne du MLF et donc
qui était chanté pour célébrer une
victoire des féministes cela dit fois
pousser la chansonnette c'était pas
encore gagné il fallait que le texte
soit aussi adopté au Sénat donc le
problème c'est que pour obtenir le vote
d'une majorité au Sénat il a fallu
modifier le texte c'est-à-dire qu'au
lieu de voter pour inscrire le droit
d'avorter dans la Constitution les
sénateurs ont préféré voter pour la
liberté d'avorter alors quelle
différence entre le droit d'avorter et
la liberté d'avorter heureusement nous
avons des meilleurs profs de droit de
Paris dans le studio qui va pouvoir nous
expliquer ça parce que moi je suis un
peu limité là-dessus en attendant droit
d'ailleurs ou liberté il en doute une
différence pas tant que ça parce que
Mathilde pano s'en est réjouie de ce
vote du Sénat c'était historique
simplement elle disait madame borne
maintenant à vous de déposer un projet
de loi alors pourquoi un projet de loi
plutôt qu'une proposition de loi parce
que une proposition de loi
constitutionnelle donc qui vient donc
des parlementaires elle doit être
soumise à un référendum pour être adopté
alors qu'un projet de loievenu du
gouvernement ben un une réunion du
Congrès de tiers du Congrès permett
d'adopter le texte donc l'avantage du
projet de loi c'est que ça évite de
faire un référendum avec surtout une
campagne qui donnera énormément temps de
parole à tous les militants
anti-avortement il sont pourtant très
peu nombreux enfin loin d'être
majoritaire dans ce pays donc il faut un
projet de loi bah ça tombe bien depuis
dimanche le président de la République a
annoncé qu'il y avait un projet de loi
simplement il a repris le terme du Sénat
donc la liberté d'avorter quelle
différence avec le droit d'avorter
heureusement il y a Benjamin
Morel on va évidemment poser la question
à Benjamin Morel mais pas tout de suite
merci à vous Stéphane blackovski
Mariepierre rixin on a vu Stéphane
rappeler un peu ce contexte la décision
de la Cour suprême américaine l'an
dernier on a vu la Pologne et la Hongrie
durcir aussi leur législation sur sur
l'avortement est-ce que vous vous sentez
monter un mouvement anti IG en France
qui pourrait menacer ce droit le les les
les antichoix comme on les appel ne ne
se révèle pas précisément aujourd'hui on
les a toujours vu à l'œuvre depuis un
certain temps ce que l'on sent ce que
l'on voit en revanche c'est la montée
des extrêmes droites en Europe en
particulier et que un des points communs
entre entre toutes les extrêmes droites
c'est de toucher notamment aux droits
des femmes qui sont un totem pour eux et
à l'intérieur de ces droits des femmes
en particulier de toucher à la liberté
des femmes de disposer de leur corps et
donc de toucher au droit à l'avortement
pas directement le pénalisant mais en
semant par exemple des embuches très
concrètes et on se rappelle notamment et
bien de l'obligation pour les Hongroises
et bien d'écouter par exemple le cœur du
fetus avant de d'avorter donc on voit à
quel point aujourd'hui i le processus
des des de l'extrême droite se
concrétise très très directement on le
voit également en Italie et autant en
fait de d'embuscade sur les droits des
femmes qui se manifestent donc très
concrètement dans la vie des femmes donc
c'est ça qui justifie à vos yeux de de
le de le protéger aujourd'hui en FR que
je le rappelle on a aussi une montée de
l'extrême droite dans notre pays mathil
Panau l'Assemblée nationale telelle
qu'elle est composé aujourd'hui en tout
cas est favorable à la
constitutionnalisation de l'IVG on l'a
vu avec votre proposition de loi qui a
été très largement majoritairement
adopté par les députés le seul bémol que
j'ai pu noter euh il vient à la fois
d'Olivier marlex pour les républicains
et de Marine Le Pen pour le
rassemblement national pour faire simple
hein l'un comme l'autre disent il y a
des choses plus urgentes que ça en
France à traiter aujourd'hui personne ne
remet en cause ce droit à quoi bon le
constitutionnaliser qu'est-ce que vous
leur répondez alors déjà c'est faux euh
et je pense que ça serait présemptueux
de notre part de croire que jamais en
France le droit à l'avortement ne sera
remis en cause cet été j'avais invité
lors des universités d'été de la France
insoumise une militante et sociologue
polonaise qui expliquait comment il
n'avait absolument pas vu venir les
restrictions extrêmement fortes à l'IVG
qui qui ont conduit à la mort de six
femmes polonaises depuis que
l'avortement a été quasiment interdit en
Pologne et en Hongrie où on oblige les
les femmes à écouter le cœur du du fetus
avant de pouvoir avorter lorsqu'elles
l'ont décidé et bien c'est le modèle par
exemple de Monsieur bardellaa du
rassemblement national et je vous
voudrais dire puisqueà côté de moi il y
a la prés qu'il a dit publiquement oui
oui que le modèle natalist de la Hongrie
était un de ses modèles il l'a dit
publiquement je voudrais dire comme la
président du planning familial et à côté
de moi déjà dire tout mon soutien à
l'ensemble des militantes du planning
familial qui quasiment toutes les
semaines depuis maintenant plusieurs
mois sont subissent des attaques de
l'extrême droite et nous avons à
l'Assemblée nationale des députés RN qui
ont été élus par exemple Madame Laure
Lavallette qui en 2014 demandait
l'abrogation totale de l'IVG mais aussi
Hervé de l'épino qui compare
l'avortement au génocide arménien
rwandais à la Choa au crime de daesh ou
encore Christophe Benz qui dit
l'avortement est un génocide de masse et
on pourrait continuer comme ça alors
après je peux rappeler quand même que
effectivement c'est le groupe politique
au sein duquel il y a eu le plus de
votes contre mais que il y a une
majorité de pour au sein du RN sur la
constitution quand vous comprez avec les
abstentions non pas une majorité mais il
a une séparation entre les votes les
abstentions les contes et les votes pour
mais ce que je veux dire par là c'est
que un il ne faut pas être présomptieux
et que ça peut arriver dans n'importe
quel pays et donc l'inscrire dans la
Constitution c'est aussi l'assurance
pour nos filles nos petites filles nos
arrièrees petites filles qu'elles
n'auront pas moins de droit que nous en
tout cas c'est le signal qui est envoyé
un signal évidemment aux militantes du
monde entier qui se battent pour le
droit à disposer de leur corps et c'est
surtout dire oui il y a des forces dans
notre pays qui sont extrêmement bien
financées qui par ailleurs mène des
agressions notamment contre le planning
familial et avec des forces comme le
rassemblement national qui continue de
militer contre l'avortement alors Sarah
du rocher on va vous entendre dans un
instant sur les raisons qui vous
poussent à à réclamer vous aussi cette
constitutionnalisation du droit à l'IVG
mais avant cela on va voir que l'accès à
l'IVG n'est pas toujours simple pour les
femmes en France notamment en raison du
regard que porte encore la société sur
cet acte qui est encore tabou c'est un
reportage de Marion beécker avec Clément
perau l'avortement est un acte médical
qui ne s'improvise pas dans cette
université parisienne des futurs
médecins et des sages femmes suivent une
formation pour approfondir leur
connaissan sur l'IVG une pratique qui
semble quelque peu délaissée voire même
méprisé c'est abordé dans nos études
plus la contraception que l'IBG selon
moi mais je trouve que c'est survolé on
sent quand même de la part de certains
collègues quelques chose de l'ordre de
pourquoi tu fais ça un peu c'est pas du
soin en
fait
la formation prépare aussi à l'accueil
des femmes un volet incontournable une
sagefemme se souvient d'une patiente
traumatisée par un psychologue en fait
elle lui avait demandé mais en fait j'ai
peur de ce qui va sortir de moi
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que je vais voir
en fait après l'IVG et il lui avait
répondu vous verrez pas grandchose vous
allez perdre un petit UF mais il y aura
deux points noirs et ce sera les yeux de
votre conscience ces témoignage mont que
l'avortement n'est pas complètement
banalisé dans le Milie
un constat qui vaut aussi dans la
société où les mouvements d' provie sont
mobilisés contre le projet de
constitutionnalisation de
l'ivgivisation on interdit la peine de
mort pour les criminels pour les
violeurs pour les pédophiles et à côté
de ça on va dire mais en fait un enfant
selon la situation selon le contexte
dans lequel il attendu on peut le tuer
les militants et les lobby
anti-avortement n'investissent pas que
la rue ils étendent aussi leur action au
champ politique
pendant l'examen du texte à l'Assemblée
cette députée a reçu une lettre bien
particulière il est mis fin à la vie
d'un être humain tel que le fétus de 12
semaines que vous tenez entre les mains
ça joue sur sur sur bah le visuel
évidemment parfois assumé parfois
souterraines les réticences àivg n'ont
pas disparu en France 20 ce sujet alors
Sara du rocher on voit dans ce reportage
que l'accès IVG est encore compliqué que
ce soit pour les femmes qui veulent
recourir à ce droit que ce soit pour le
personnel de santé qui souhaite pouvoir
aussi pratiquer ces actes quelles sont
les les principales difficultés
auxquelles sont confrontées les femmes
qui se tourne vers vous au planning
familial alors peut-être dire quand même
que en effet on on alerte de manière
très régulière sur les difficultés
d'accès à l'avortement une des choses
qui nous motiv aujourd'hui de faire
rentrer l'avortement dans la
Constitution c'est de dire que l'accès à
l'avortement est menacé en France et que
l'avortement est menactionaliser un
droit ou une liberté ça on va en
débattre est une façon d'améliorer selon
vous de garantir l'acè c'est à
l'IVG c'est juste l'inscrire comme un
droit fondamental et aussi mettre face
aux responsables politiques le fait que
c'est un droit fondamental et que
forcément il faut faire quelque chose
concernant l'accès puisque nous en fait
au quotidien on voit des difficultés
pour des femmes à avoir une vraie une
réelle information parce que ces
mouvements antichoix font de la
désinformation ont beaucoup d'argent et
bien évidemment créer des sites et
s'adresse directement aux personnes
l'autre chose c'est le parcours de
l'avortement qui est encore très lourd
ça veut dire qu'il y a des femmes qui
sont parfois obligées de passer de
département à un autre département parce
qu'il n'y a pas de médecin pour
pratiquer l'avortement et donc pour nous
évidemment que il y a une urgence à
réagir par rapport à ça on alerte de
manière très régulière et je pense que c
deux combats qui sont très liés euh en
tout cas est-ce que vous constatez par
exemple une hausse du nombre de médecins
qui
euh veulent utiliser leurs clauses de
conscience pour ne pas pratiquer
l'avortement est-ce que c'est quelque
chose que je pense qu'il faut peut-être
déjà dire que en effet l'avortement est
un acte à part encore une fois dans la
loi puisque il y a une clause de
conscience spécifique à l'avortement
c'est le seul acte en France il y a une
clause de conscience qui existe pour
tous les actes sur l'avortement il y en
a une particulière qui a été inscrite
dans dans la loi de Simone veille c'est
quelque chose qui nous convient pas nous
on aimerait que cette clause n'existe
plus ça a été dans la proposition de loi
qui avait été faite par Alban Gillot et
ça avait pas été retenu bien évidemment
mais en attendant nous en effet on a
aucun regard aujourd'hui sur le nombre
de médecins qui refuse mais par contre
nous ce qu'on voit sur le terrain c'est
que des femmes n'arrivent pas à trouver
aujourd'hui l'accès à l'avortement et
Laib possibilité d'avorter et aussi dire
juste par rapport au chiffres que vous
disiez au
départ en fait les femmes si elles
veulent avorter elles avorteront elles
sont capables de faire 90 km pour
avorter elles sont capables de faire
1000 km pour avorter vous faites
référence au chiffres publiés hier
234000 IVG en France un plus haut depuis
1990 ce qui alerte tous les journalistes
et ce qui alerte le monde entier nous ça
nous alerte pas ça veut simplement dire
que aujourd'hui il y a des femmes qui
décident et qui choisissent d'avorter
mais bien évidemment que parfois ça
c'est très compliqué et ça c'est des
chose que l'on voit au quotidien d'un
mot Mathilde Panau évoqué des menaces
dont font l'objet les militantes les
militants du planning familial vous
confirmez vous-même personnellement ah
oui tout à fait ça veut dire que là
depuis à peu près le mois de mars il y a
il y a des attaques auprès des antennes
des intimidation des humiliations aussi
qui peuvent être faites et des menaces
directes envers des militantes on voit
un contexte montter mais je pense que
c'est lié sur les questions d'avortement
également sur l'éducation à la sexualité
Benjamin Morel on va se pencher avec
vous si vous voulez bien sur la
procédure de constitutionnalisation
qu'Emmanuel Macron a décidé d'engager là
dans les jours qui viennent mais d'abord
sur le principe même de
constitutionnaliser ce droit est-ce que
c'est une protection vraiment efficace
parce que la Constitution on peut la
réviser dans un sens comme dans l'autre
c'est dur à dire parce qu'en réalité
vous savez les juristes ont construit
des murs de papier mais ces murs de
papier ne sont que de papier donc face
aux politiques ensuite et bien des
choses peuvent se passer alors oui
c'est-à-dire que on a aujourd'hui une
garantie quand même du de l'IVG au sein
de la Constitution mais lié à la
jurisprudence on a une jurisprudence de
2001 confirmé en 2017 qui fait que le
Conseil constitutionnel en s'appuyant
sur la sur l'article 2 de la DDHC la
déclaration de droit de l'homme et du
citoyen garanti mais ça reste de la
jurisprudence et donc si le juge change
d'avis demain on peut avoir un
revirement de jurisprudence l'avantage
de constitutionnaliser c'est qu'on
solidifie on garantit un peu plus la
présence de livg dans la Constitution et
donc on fait qu'il est plus difficile de
rétropédaler mais est-ce que ça garantit
ensuite l'exercice réel de ce droit bah
ça dépend ce qu'on met dedans et ça
dépense qu'on fera le juge c'est-à-dire
que évidemment c'est utile je crois pas
qu'il faut non plus être tout à fait
idylique et naïf sur ce qu'est un juge
un juge évidemment ça a une marge
d'appréciation vous savez la Cour
suprême américaine le problème aux
États-Unis il y a eu des RIC pour
revenir sur l'IVG ils ont jamais été
positifs le problème aux États-Unis ça a
été le juge en se basant sur les mêmes
fondements la Cour suprême américaine a
interdit l'esclavage et avant
l'autoriser donc il faut voir que malgré
tout cette garantie ça sera Infiné ce
qu'en fera le juge le juge peut varier
le juge peut bouger et donc il n'est
jamais une garantie tout à fait
essentiel absolu et indiscutable alors
il y avait plusieurs options sur la
table he pour constitutionnaliser l'IVG
on va revoir le message posté par
Emmanuel Macron ce dimanche sur le
réseau social x anciennement Twitter en
2024 la liberté des femmes de recourir à
l'IVG sera irréversible le chef de
l'État a donc repris le mot de liberté
et non de droit ça veut dire qu'il a
repris quelque part la formulation que
Philippe Bas avait fait adopter au Sénat
lors de l'examen de votre texte Mathilde
panneau on va réécouter les arguments
qu'il avait employés à l'époque il n'y a
pas de droit absolu il y a une liberté
déjà reconnu et que nous pouvons écrire
dans la Constitution mais à la condition
qu'il y ait une conciliation entre les
droit de la femme
enceinte de mettre fin à sa grossesse et
la protection de l'enfant à naître après
un certain délai donc mathil Panau
Philippe Bas quand il défend cette
formulation refuse de reconnaître un
droit obsolu à l'IVG il préfère donc
constitutionnaliser la liberté plutôt
que le droit à l'IVG vous craignez que
ce soit moins protecteur pour les femmes
alors bon sur la manière dont il y aura
des jurisprudences derrière et ce que ça
créera y compris sur des principes de
non régression ce qui est ce qui
pourrait nous intéresser ici ça seulle
l'histoire nous le dira mais moi moi je
je suis attaché au fait que on réindique
que le droit à l'avortement est un droit
fondamental humain et c'est pourquoi
nous nous avions proposé une formulation
qui d'ailleurs au départ
constitutionnalisit à la fois le droit à
l'avortement mais aussi ce qui était son
corollaire le droit à la contraception
alors peut-être qu'on y arrivera plus
tard mais moi je vais vous dire ce n'est
pas ma formulation celle du Sénat et
pourtant nous étions prêt dans la niche
parlementaire que nous avions le 30
novembre à l'inscrire de nouveau pour
l'adopter dans les mêmes terme que celui
qui est que celle qui a été faite au
Sénat pourquoi parce que depuis le 8
mars 2022 le président de la République
avait promis de constitutionnaliser
l'IVG depuis le 8 mars 2022 nous avions
manifesté nous avions fait des pétitions
fait des lettres fait des
interpellations et donc en quelque sorte
nous attendions que ce projet de loi
arrive ça veut dire que vous allez voter
cette révision constitutionnelle avec la
formulation personne ne sait tout le
monde sait que la norme suprême il n'y a
aucun marbre assez solide pour graver
pour l'éternité un droit fondamental
humain comme celui du droit à
l'avortement mais il n'empêche que c'est
un signal politique extrêmement
important de dire nous voulons en
quelque sorte garantir consolider
solidifier un droit comme celui du droit
à l'avortement donc évidemment pour le
évidemment pour les femmes de France
mais aussi pour l'ensemble des
militantes qui se battent partout dans
le monde je crois que c'est un signal
politique qui mérite bon je n'aime pas
cette formulation mais évidemment je la
voterai et j'espère bien que dans la
Constituante on fera en sorte d'avoir
une meilleure formulation par la suite
Benjamin Morel le regard du du
constitutionnaliste est-ce que c'est
moins protecteur de constitutionnaliser
une liberté plutôt qu'un droit alors il
faut comprendre la différence quand vous
constitutionnalisez un droit vous faites
du Conseil constitutionnel l'arbitre des
élégances c'est lui en fait qui va
déterminer ce droit c'est une bonne
chose parce que ça peut permettre en
effet d'éviter des dérive du législateur
d'avoir un effet cliqué le fait que on
ne revienne pas sur certaines modalités
d'exercice de ce droit il peut y avoir
également un danger qui un danger de
régidification regardez ce qui s'est
passé en Allemagne la cour de carlou a
été jusqu'à la cour constitionnelle
allemande a été jusqu'à définir le délai
entre la consultation d'un médecin et la
réalisation de l'acte est-ce que ça
dépend vraiment d'une cour et pas du
législateur c'est ça qui peut inquiéter
un certain nombre de parlementair la
liberté ça renvoie à un autre régime de
compétence le principe et les garanties
mais ensuite les modalités d'exercice de
cette liberté et c'est pas un hasard si
on article on va inscrire selon Emmanuel
Macron ce terme à l'article 24 34 de la
Constitution l'article 34 c'est ce qui
prévoit le domaine de la loi c'est ce
qui est de la compétence justement du
législateur donc ça laisse une marge
d'appréciationement c'estàdire que le
principe il est constitionalisé mais ce
que l'on en fait c'est le Parlement qui
ensuite le décide par exemple qu'est-ce
que Conseil constitutionnel ferait si un
législateur à l'avenir décidait de
réduire à 4 semaines le nombre de
semaines de
grossesse pour pouvoir pratiquer l'IVG
vous AZ déjà dit que le juge était
parfois fortement imprévisible donc
aujourd'hui bien malin celui qui saurait
vous le dire de manière certaine
c'est-à-dire qu'on peut avoir un conseil
consuel qui juge que en la matière et
ben il peut pas y avoir de régression et
donc ce faisant vous ne pouvez aller que
vers une progression des droits on peut
avoir un conseil consel qui dit
simplement je garantis le principe le
législateur fait ce qu'il veut ça on
saura dans 10 ans dans 20 ans dans 30
ans Mariepierre Xin est-ce que vous vous
auriez à titre personnel préféré
constitutionnaliser le droit à l'IVG
plutôt que la liberté d'y recourir c'est
d'abord ce que je souhaiterais dire
c'est qu'une constitution elle raconte
aussi quelque chose de notre de notre
société euh et je crois aujourd'hui que
il est temps euh que ce droit
fondamental euh des femmes à disposé de
leur corps qui est donc une garantie
également pour les femmes à disposer de
leur vie rappelons-le soit inscrit dans
la Constitution en effet pour euh et
bien le le le le consolider euh je
partage le fait que nul ne peut savoir
euh d'ici 20 ou 30 ans ce que deviendra
ce droit mais il est de notre
responsabilité de le consolider au
maximum euh également avec une
une conscience de ce que sont les
réalités politiques du pays euh et donc
je crois en effet qu'il faut faire avec
les différentes composantes politiques
de notre de notre pays quand vous
regardez la rédaction à ce stade
proposée par le Président de la
République on va peut-être la voir
d'ailleurs elle a été donnée par la
tribune du dimanche voilà sachant que
pour l'instant le le le texte va être
prochainement déposé devant le Conseil
d'État euh il il a il y a également il y
a le sujet de de la liberté mais il y a
également le sujet de la garantie qui un
élément supplémentaire par rapport à la
rédaction du Sénat de manière
effectivement à apporter euh si j'ose
dire des garanties supplémentaires à la
rédaction euh du Sénat euh dire
également que
euh c'est un sujet en effet pour les
générations futures mais on a également
et je partage ce que disait le planning
familial également un sujet d'accès à
l'IVG dans le dans le pays et soyons
honnêtes le l'inscrire dans la
Constitution apporte une garantie
supplémentaire pour les les femmes
aujourd'hui dans notre pays mais il
faudra également que parallèlement
travailler sur le
faut que nous avancions notamment avec
les agences régionales de santé pour que
ce droit soit effectif dans toute la
définition c'est-à-dire la liberté des
femmes d'avorter mais également la
liberté des modalités d'avorter on en
parle moins souvent mais c'est important
or aujourd'hui cette liberté n'est pas
effective sur l'ensemble du pays et je
vois notamment dans certaines zones
rural par exemple où et bien cette cet
accès est beaucoup plus difficile que
dans S dans d'autres territoire il faut
que nous arrivions à fluidifier le
parcours des femmes qui veulent avorter
et je dirais même qu'il faut que nous
facilitions l'accès à l'IVG dans le pays
d'un mot le corollaire de l'initiative
d'Emmanuel Macron c'est que cette
révision de la Constitution va pouvoir
être adoptée par le Congrès donc députés
et sénateurs réunis en congrès avec une
majorité des 3/5e plutôt que par
référendum c'est une bonne chose selon
vous alors ça me semble absolument
essentiel et tous ceux qui partagent le
fait de voir l'IVG inscrit dans la
Constitution aujourd'hui je crois hein
se rassemble autour de l'idée du Congrès
pour ne pas en effet raviver encore
davantage des forces réactionnaires qui
seraient opposé à l'IVG avec là encore
et bien soumettre ce ce cette cette
question à un référendum ne garantit pas
et bien de l'issue de de de de de ce
texte et enverrait si si si jamais si si
si malheureusement le texte était rejeté
un signal désastreux dans le monde
entier sur ce pointl un point là-dessus
nous si on l'avait inscrit dans la niche
parlementaire du 30 novembre et nous on
attend qu'il y ait un texte déposé avec
un calendrier donc des actes parce qu'on
est vigilante Tex doit être soumis cette
semaine au Conseil d'État en conseil des
ministres d'ici à la fin de l'année mais
je le dis ici nous sommes plusieurs que
ça soit côté parlementaire ou y compris
d'ailleurs dans les mouvements
féministes qui parce que je le rappelle
derrière une loi constitutionnelle il y
a toujours une foule et notamment des
femmes qui se battent depuis des années
sur cette question nous sommes prêtes à
aller au référendum si besoin que nous
gagnerions parce que là on regarde sans
campagne nous sommes à 87 % des
personnes interrogées qui sont
favorables à la constitutionnalisation
de l'IVG et je le dis d'autant plus
solennellement que si nous n'allons pas
jusqu'aux actes de de faire en sorte que
ça soit constitutionnalisé dans euh la
Constitution alors on se réserve le
droit de terminer le processus
parlementaire et pour la première fois
de la 5e République d'Ager jusqu'au
référendum et y compris d'inflager une
défaite aux antichoix et aux antidroits
Jean-Louis bourlange vous êtes memre du
MoDem qui est en France l'héritier si
l'on peut dire de la démocratie
chrétienne comment est-ce que vous vous
positionnez de la démocratie chrétienne
oui écoutez moi j'ai j'ai commencé ma
mon action politique parlementaire au
côté de Simone veille donc il est
inutile de vous dire que je suis
extrêmement sensible à ce thème et que
je je trouve que le droit ou la liberté
j'ai du mal à je dois dire je suis
peut-être un peu grossier mais j'ai du
mal à saisir la la la différence de
portée réelle entre les deux termes mais
je considère que ça doit effectivement
être conforté alors le problème qui se
pose c'est est-ce qu'il y a comme le dit
la présidente panneau est-ce qu'il y a
un risque de subversion de ce droit
comme vous le dites aussi actuellement
alors je je crois que en France non je
pense qu'en France il n'y a aucun risque
mais je vois bien que que dans
l'ensemble du monde il y a tout un
ensemble tout un ensemble de forces et
notamment en Europe on a eu la Pologne
on a eu la Hongrie on en aura d'autres
qui effectivement font peser sur cette
liberté une menace donc je crois qu'il
n'y a pas que c'est plutôt en terme de
principe de précaution c'est plutôt
utile de constitutionnaliser ce droit
tout en reconnaissant ce que vous disiez
c'est-à-dire que la Constitution c'est
une protection de plus mais c'est pas
une protection absolue on peut changer
la Constitution comme on peut changer la
loi c'est un peu plus compliqué sur le
référendum je crois que votre argument
disant qu'on pourrait perdre est quand
même très mauvais parce que si vraiment
les Français sont contre c'est assez
difficile de leur dire qu'ils n'ont pas
le droit de s'exprimer je crois que
l'argument madame pano est meilleur le
référendum sera assurément gagné s'il
avait lieu s'il était par les partisans
de de l'IVG et il serait gagné et ça
effectivement ça consacrerait très
profondément dans l'opinion ce ce droit
vous seriez plus favorable à à l'option
du référendum parce que ça donnerait
autant de TS de parole hein dans la
campagne du référendum au pro et aux
antiou je suis très je suis une façon
Gén de façon générale je suis très
attaché à la démocratie représentative
et très hostile au caractère
simplificateur du référendum donc moi là
je ne suis je suis je je suis en un peu
en en marche de beaucoup de courants qui
sont ceux dans la majorité je pense que
il faut améliorer la démocratie
représentative améliorer la délibération
parlementaire si le référendum c'est ça
ne permet jamais de faire une synthèse
alors là il y a pas il y a pas de
synthèse on est pour on est contre mais
malgré tout je trouve qu'il faut
s'approcher avec beaucoup de prudence et
très franchement avec tout ce qui se
passe actuellement mobiliser l'ensemble
du corps électoral sur cela quand on
voit ce qui se passe au Moyen-Orient
on va passer en deè on va parler avec
vous en deuxème partie d'émission j'ai
juste encore une dernière question à
poser à à Sarah du rocher sur bah la
perspective de ce vote il faut quand
même rassembler 35è des voix du Congrès
donc députés et sénateurs réunis on a vu
dans le reportage de Marion Becker et
Clément per que il y a tout un travail
de lobbying qui est mené par les antiivg
vous êtes confiante sur ce sur ce vote
écoutez oui je suis confiante ça veut
dire que pour moi en tout cas il y a eu
tout un travail qui a été fait parce que
faut pas oublier en effet qu'il y a eu
un gros travail qui a été fait avec les
associations fémin ministres les
parlementaires et que en effet derrière
ça fait un an plus d'un an qu'on y
travaille donc bien évidemment que on
sera dans la suite et dans la course en
effet pour faire en sorte ensemble de
faire rentrer l'avortement dans la
Constitution ça ne sera pas simple tout
simplement puisque les moyens financiers
des antichoix sont assez impressionnants
il va falloir aussi que les
parlementaires prennent leur
responsabilité d'avoir une parole
politique forte engagée et évidemment
que ça sera une nouvelle bataille à voir
mais on n'est pas enfin nous en tant que
féministe c'est pas la première ni la
dernière et en tout cas on vous êtes
prêt à mener la bataille tout à fait et
si en plus en effet ça nous donne aussi
des opportunités parce que moi je suis
vraiment pas d'accord sur la question
des menaces le droit on a fait que
progresser mais c'est grâce aux
associations féministes aux politiques
et aux parlementaires alliés mais je
crois qu'il ne faut pas se mettre de
vraiment à voile sur les yeux je le dis
ça veut dire que de penser que la France
sera une exception et que les l'extrême
droite et la droite conservatrice ne
toucherait pas à l'avortement si elle
arrivait au pouvoir je pense vraiment
que c'est se Tromp R
merci beaucoup c'est fin de ce débat
merci à à tous les quatre d'être venus
sur le le plateau de sa vous regarde
dans une dizaine de minutes la parole
sera à nos afranchis mais ils sont déjà
là en coulisse regardez avec Richard
verli on reviendra avec vous sur la la
passe d'armes qui a opposé Victor Orban
à Emmanuel Macron sur l'Union européenne
ces derniers jours Cécilia gabizon va
nous expliquer pourquoi l'émoji clin
d'œil doit être utilisé avec modération
enfin Elsa mingava de quoi sera-t-il
question dans votre chronique Bourbon
Express je vais vous parler des fait
d'otage retenu par le Hamas elles
étaient reçues à l'Assemblée aujourd'hui
merci à tous les trois et à tout à
l'heure Jean-Louis bourlange vous restez
avec nous vous êtes notre grand témoin
ce soir on va évoquer avec vous très
honoré la situation internationale car
vous présidez je le rappelle la
commission des affaires étrangères à
l'Assemblée mais d'abord votre portrait
qui est signé Marco
Pomier si on vous invite Jean-Louis
bourlange c'est pour avoir votre regard
sur cet ordre mondial bouleversé alors
que accident paraît plus que jamais
impuissant face au conflits multiples
terrorisme en Europe invasion de
l'Ukraine offensive de l'Azerbaïdjan
dans le haut cararabak et bien sûr cette
guerre entre Israël et le Hamas
situation humanitaire catastrophique à
Gaza bombardé sans relâche par l'armée
israélienne la réplique des massacres du
7 octobre une guerre qui enflamme les
débats de l'assembléeèg vous vous
abandonnez à la pente inarrêtable de la
guerre on les filles et
votre position elle a marqué les esprits
Jean-Louis bourlange on vous a vu
affaibl etouffler sur uneé excuse-moi je
me sens pas très bien mais vous êtes
allé au bout de votre discours
condamnant l'attaque terroriste du Hamas
tout en critiquant la politique de benam
n le gouvernement
israélien'est estimé libre d'engager
sans risque une relance rampante mais
brut et déterminé de sa politique de
colonisation en
Jordanie applaudit sur les bancs de la
gauche moins apprécié dans votre propre
camp peu connu du grand public
Jean-Louis bourlange votre réputation
n'est plus à faire à l'Assemblée 2017
vous sortez de votre retraite politique
anticipée pour soutenir le candidat
Macron député MoDem depuis 6 ans
président de la prestigieuse commission
des affaires étrangères de vous nous
retenons aussi l'énarque passionné
d'Europe entré au Parlement de
Strasbourg en 19
sur la liste d'unee Simone veille le
fait que ce soit elle qui choisisse
l'Europe c'était infiniment porteur ça
voulait dire que tout le monde devait
choisir l'UR l'Europe qui affronte
aujourd'hui le retour de la guerre plus
de 600 jours d'offensive militaire russe
en Ukraine et un conflit qui s'enlise
mais éclipsé aujourd'hui par le proche-
Orient qui s'embrase des crises articulé
les unes aux autres dites-vous derrière
le Hamas il y a le hbolla derrière
lezbolla il y a l'Iran derrière l'Iran
il y a la Russie et la Chine alors
Jean-Louis bourlange dans ce monde
instable intranquille que peut faire la
France pour éviter l'embrasement
général et je vais vous poser cette
question évidemment jean-l bourlange
mais d'abord cette dernière information
qui nous est donnée par le k d'orsé ce
soir deux enfants français ont été tués
dans le nord de la bande de Gaza leur
mère a été blessé Jean-Louis bourlange
la France a longtemps porté une voix
d'équilibre qui été entendu et respecté
par les deux camps au proche- Orient
aujourd'hui on a l'impression que la
France redécouvre un peu ce dossier du
Proche Orient après avoir laissé le
laisser aux mains des des
États-Unis je reformule un peu la
question de Marco Pomier que doit faire
la France pour peser à nouveau dans les
dans la région pour RER à une
désescalade écoutez je crois que ce
n'est pas simplement la France c'est
l'Europe qui s'était mobilisé très
fortement sur la la France seule ne peut
ne peut ne peut pas j'ai pas dit ça h
bien sûr la France peut pas c'est
évident on va pas intervenir
militairement sur la bande de Gaza dire
à l'État d'Israël faut faire si c et ça
s'il ne veut pas le faire c'est c'est
une évidence nous sommes une puissance
moyenne nous sommes dotés d'armes
puissantes nous pouvons nous défendre
nous pouvons agir nous pouvons aider
mais nous ne pouvons pas décider à la
place des autres mais l'Europe j reviens
avait des avait vraiment pris une
position la déclaration de Venise qui
est de quoi de 80 c'est très très vieux
tout ça on avait pris position
clairement pour une solution à deux
états pourquoi l'avait-on fait parce que
c'est comme ça qu'on avait fait l'Europe
on avait dit les Allemands les Français
ça avait été assez assez chaud hein
pendant plus d'un siècle et on avait dit
si on veut s'en tirer si on veut vivre
en paix tranquillement il faut qu'on
respecte l'autre il faut que les
intérêts légitimes de chacun des
protagonistes soit reconnu et ce que
nous avons dit avec les deux états
c'était je je discutais avec un un
ancien ambassadeur qui me rappelait un
déjeuner qu'il avait eu avec Rabine
là-dessus et Rabine lui disait nous
avons une une un court moment où nous
pouvons réaliser cela et ce qui s'est
passé et la France était évidemment la
France était très porteuse de cela elle
avait embrayé l'Europe et puis ce qui
s'est passé c'est que les États-Unis
n'ont pas vraiment suivi ils ont suivi à
un moment et puis après l'assassinat de
Rabine l'assassinat de Sadat on est
passé vers quelque chose de très
différent et qui de qu'on dont on voit
aujourd'hui les conséquences négatives
parce que effectivement le sentiment que
j'ai c'est que la sécurité profonde
d'Israël ne sera pas durablement assurée
si il n'y a
pas un environnement pacifié autourou
vous parliez d'un d'un état vulnérable
dans votre discours la semaine dernière
à l'Assemblée nationale vous avez dit il
y a 15 il y a 15 millions de Juifs dans
le monde 6 6 millions à peu près en
Israël et il y a 15ard 500 million de
musulmans vous avezè vous avez vous avez
eu ces mots la violence barbare du Hamas
et sans excuses mais pas sans cause dans
votre discours vous avez clairement
condamné les actes terroristes à viser
génocidaire du Hamas mais vous avez
également condamné la politique de
colonisation du gouvernement israélien
de de Benjamin netanahou c'est un
discours que certains ont qualifié de de
chirakien personne ne l'a qualifié de
macroniste pourquoi selon vous écoutez
je je ne sais pas c'est parce que
peut-être Emmanuel Macron ne sétait pas
encore exprimé quand j'ai quand j'ai
prononcé mon quand j'ai prononcer ce ce
discours euh c'est
c'est c'est c'est vrai que ça s'inscrit
dans la grande tradition
françaiseette celle de Chirac et alors
Emmanuel Macron non regardez ce que le
voyage Emmanuel Macron a été dans le bon
sens à part ce que je considère comme
une expression vraiment pas très
heureuse qui est l'appel à la à la
coalition internation à la coalition ça
je crois que c'est pas du tout la phrase
qu'il fallait le mot qu'il fallait
employer mais en revanche ma par rapport
à pas mal le chef d'État de gouvernement
a fait le travail avec tout le monde il
est il a parlé aux autorités israélienne
bien entendu il a parlé aux autorités à
l'Autorité palestinienne il a été voir
le roi Abdallah jordaniie il a été voir
le maréchal si donc tous les
protagonistes et il a rappelé notre
notre volonté de contribuer à aux deux
états vous l'avez entendu condamner la
la colonisation de laassjordanie oui il
il a dit des choses qui étit condamné
oui il a dit des choses qui étaient
assez nettes à divers moments mais le le
problème le problème n'est pas là si je
puis me dire le problème c'est que nous
sommes engagés actuellement au
Moyen-Orient dans un processus
absolument terrifiant moi je ne sais pas
je ne vois pas exactement ce que je
comprends très très bien le droit à la
légitime défense d'Israël hein les
violences qui ont
été subies par le peuple par le peuple
israélien j'ai parlé de crime de guerre
de crime contre l'humanité de terrorisme
tout ça est totalement vrai mais
aujourd'hui quel est le but politique de
cette de de ces bombardements
systématiques en à Gaza comment le le
Premier ministre israélien envisage-t-il
de trouver une sortie politique on a 2
300000 personnes dans la bande de Gaza
qu'est-ce qu'on quel est le type de
relation qui va s éblir entre Israël et
ces 2300000 et en même temps en en 6
Jordanie je suis inquiet parce que je
vois que l'idée et de confier aux colons
qui sont vraiment juges et partis une
sorte de de de les transformer en une
sorte de garde nationale et ça ça veut
dire que la partie elle va être très
dure pour les Palestiniens qui vont être
victimes de d'expropriation voire de de
de de de mise à mort ce qui s'est passé
au cours des deux dernières années n'est
pas au des dernières années n'est pas
brillant donc je crois qu'Israël doit
revenir absolument à sa logique qui
était celle de Shimon Perez celle
d'Isaac Rabine de dire nous n'aurons la
paix que si nous offrons à nos voisins
un un un avenir qui correspond à ce don
ce à quoi ils ont droit c'est très
difficile et je crois que l'Europe et
l'Europe me paraît très divisé très
incapable d'agir moi je suis un Européen
convaincu mais je ne suis pas un
Européen heureux voyez-vous parce que je
trouve que l'Europe n'en fait pas assez
je crois que nous devons peser pour
cette solution qui est la seule solution
qui permettra à Israël de vivre
durablement en sécurité et en paix dans
dans votre discours toujours he j'y
reviens vous avez eu une autre phrase où
vous expliquez que on l'a entendu
d'ailleurs hein dans le sujet de Marco
Pomier derrière le hzbollah derrière le
Hamas il y a le hzbollah derrière le
hzbollah il y a l'Iran derrière l'Iran
il y a la Russie il y a la Chine est-ce
que cette donnée là aujourd'hui elle est
suffisamment prise en compte et
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire face à ça
pour éviter cette oui ce que j'ai voulu
dire simplement c'était un extrait mais
ce que j'ai voulu dire simplement c'est
qu'il y avait un risque
d'escalade que si le Hamas est trop
massacré le hzbollah va intervenir si le
hzbollah est massacré l'Iran peut
intervenir et cetera il y a une un
risque de ce que kusv'appelle
l'ascension aux extrêmeson c'est très
réel je crois qu'il y a des puissances
modératrice d'abord nous mais nous ne
sommes pas très puissant surtout tout
les
États-Unis les
États-Unis je crois font une pression
extrêmement forte sur dans l'ensemble de
la zone notamment sur le Premier
ministre israélien pour qu'il en fasse
pas trop trop pour l'instant c'est pas
c'est pas écouté mais notamment je pense
que les Américains seraient très très
hostille à des attaques puisqueà un
moment monsieur netanahou a dit qu'il
voulait aplatir le Liban à des attaques
sur le Liban puis il y a le problème de
l'Iran l'Iran c'est un un état très
assez assez machiavellique c'est le
moins qu'on puisse dire assez
intelligent et là il me semble que c'est
eux qui manipulent par exemple c'est eux
qui empêchent alors que les gens du
hzbollah voudraient intervenir je pense
que c'est eux qui empêchent le chef du
hbollah de déclencher la guerre et c'est
eux qui en à mon avis au Yémen arme les
outils en leur disant là on fait un peu
une une attaque contre Israël mais c'est
relativement limité parce qu'il me
semble que les Iraniens n'ont pas
intérêt à à ce qu'il estit une escalade
fondamentale aujourd'hui mais vous voyez
à quel point ça à quel point ce système
est terriblement dangereux nous avons
une logique d'escalade d'un côté et nous
avons des état les États-Unis le le
l'Iran qui pour des raisons totalement
différentes l'amour de la paix je crois
pour les et de la stabilité pour les
États-Unis et la protection de l'Iran
qui ne veut pas s'exposer à à à des
catastrophes agit mais je je trouve
qu'il y a là un très grand danger mais
le principal danger c'est que va-t-on
faire en Palestine des Palestiniens
quand cette horrible guerre sera
terminée je je voudrais vous faire
réagir à une image qui a marqué
l'actualité aujourd'hui en France ce
sont ces étoiles de de David qui ont été
taguées sur de nombreuses façades
d'immeubles à Paris dans plusieurs
villes de la de la région parisienne on
craignait l'importation du conflit
israélo-palestinien en France est-ce
qu'on a pas d'ors et déjà dépasser ce
stade quand on voit ces ces tagues
antisémite moi je suis je je crois que
c'est tragiquement logique que d'avoir
un développement de de la tension entre
les Arabes et et et et les Juifs ce qui
s'est passé nous avons quand même en
France à peu près 5 ou 6 millions de
musulmans et et nous avons combien
400000 Juifs donc je comprends vraiment
très très bien que les Juifs se sentent
en situation de très grande
vulnérabilité on a des tas de
témoignages ils veulent pas plus mettre
la kipa ils veulent veent pas ils sont
extrêmement prudents ils se ils ne
s'affichent pas et cetera ils ont le
sentiment tout à fait légitime que ça
recommence h que ça recommence alors je
précise évidemment que pour l'instant on
a aucune idée de qui est
derrière ces inscriptions sur les sur
les façades d'immeubles mais ça traduit
clairement une monté de
l'antisémitismeantismitisme
l'antisémitisme est très très
précisément un antisémitisme arabe en
réalité c'est c'est c'est pas du tout
l'antisémit traditionnel de la
bourgeoisie française que nous avons
connu et qui n'est pas l'honneur de
cette bourgeoisie dans les années 30 par
exemple mais au 40 c'est c'est autre
chose mais moi je je crois que le la le
le problème que ce qu'a montré ce ce ce
que montre cette crise c'est la
vulnérabilité du peuple juif et ça c'est
quand même terrible nous ne pouvons pas
accepter ça nous ne pouvons pas accepter
que après ce qui s'est passé entre 40 et
45 nous pouvons pas accepter que c'est
les Juifs soient à nouveau dans une
situation terrible mais la vraie réponse
c'est le contraire de ce que fait le
premier ministre israélien pas seulement
depuis 15 jours depuis depuis une
dizaine d'années il a vraiment fait
déraper la politique israélienne dans
dans une direction qui à mon avis la
conduit à l'impasse et là je crois qu'il
faut vraiment que la communauté
internationale se ressaisisse et et
c'est et que le peuple israélien parce
que il y a aussi les otages euh les
otages les gens veulent euh on va en
parler avec avec elsamand d'Ava dans
dans un instant je voulais quand même
d'un mot vous entendre sur le rôle de la
Chine et de la Russie aujourd'hui dans
ce désordre mondial croissant on a
l'impression que beaucoup d'États du Sud
se rangent systématiquement derrière la
Chine et la Russie aujourd'hui qui sont
des régimes autoritaires que l'Occident
a un effet repoussoir que les
démocraties occidentales ne sont plus un
modèle pour le sud aujourd'hui que doit
faire l'Europe face à ça est-ce qu'elle
doit intégrer cette donne et adapter un
peu ses alliances stratégiques ou est-ce
qu'elle doit chercher à à lutter contre
ce mouvement qui est engagé moi je ne
crois pas à la notion de Sud global je
crois qu'il y a effectivement des
dictatures tyranniques très fortes la
Russie la Chine mais vous avez une très
grande démocratie comme l'Inde c'est une
démocratie imparfaite mais c'est une
démocratie qui est totalement étrangère
à ce à à ce phénomène vous avez un pays
comme le Brésil qui avait les premières
déclarations du du président Loula
n'était pas très heureuse sur l'Ukraine
mais depuis il a fait mieux il a déposé
une résolution que nous Français nous
avons voté qui est une résolution très
équilibrée je crois que le modèle mais
c'est vrai que le modèle démocratique
euh à du plond dans l'ail actuellement y
compris chez nousou y compris en y
compris en Europe euh je me réjouis
quand même au milieu de tout ça de voir
que les Polonais ont voté dans un sens
qui euh permet d'en faire à nouveau des
partenaires extrêmement actifs et
positifs dans l'Union européenne on en a
bien besoin donc vous êtes un pessimiste
actif comme vous définissez mais pimiste
vous vous réjouissez quand il y a quand
même des bonnes nouvelles dans dans
cette situation internationale Merci à
VOUS Jean-Louis bourlange vous restez
avec nous on accueille à présent nos
affranchi les voilà les voilà ils vont
s'installer Cécilia gabizon Richard verl
et Elsa mondain Gava installz vous
prenez siège on commence par vous Elsa
avec votre chronique Bourbon Express
l'histoire du jour à l'Assemblée oui ben
Jean-Louis bourlange vous en parliez je
vais vous parler des familles d'otage on
a vécu un moment d'émotion tout à
l'heure lors de la séance de question au
gouvernement quand la présidente yel
Bron pivé a salué la présence justement
en tribune de ses familles d'otage
depuis l'attaque terroriste du 7 octobre
dernier nous déplorons la mort de 35 de
nos compatriotes cela fait aujourd'hui
25 jours que neuf Français sont détenus
en
otage leur famille sont donc présentes
et je vous
remercie au nom de la représentation
nationale de leur dire collectivement
que nous sommes à leur
côté voilà un hémicycle debout
absolument unanime c'est un moment rare
en ce moment ça a pas été le cas pendant
toute la séance de question au
gouvernement mais là le soutien était
plein et en
pour soutenir ces familles d'otage
détenu par le Hamas et El ces familles
avaient été reçu un peu plus tôt par un
groupe de députés oui c'était à midi à
la questure ces familles d'otage elles
avaient été invitées par les
républicains il y avait le président du
parti Eric cotti il y avait là sur la
droite le député de la circonscription
meilleur Habib mais aussi le député
Renaissance Mathieu lefève c'est le
président du groupe d'amitié France
Israël des députés donc de droite de la
majorité mais aussi du rassemblement
national et du Parti socialiste un peu
plus tard la présidente de l'Assemblée
est venue aussi saluer ses otages en
marque de soutien écouz Éric siti donc à
l'initiative de cette rencontre oui
aujourd'hui depuis l'Assemblée nationale
nous vous disons
unanimement en tout cas de ceux qui sont
ici quel que soi nos appartenances nos
groupes politiques notre indéfectible
soutien notre entière
mobilisation nous ne cesserons pas ce
combat à vos côtés pour la libération
des otages alors ces familles d'otage
évidemment elles avaient un seul message
libéer les otages libézles au plus vite
elles l'ont répété devant les
journalistes devant les députés présents
et elles ont chacune partagé leurs
histoires nous sommes les petits enfants
de Yafa Hadar elle a 85 ans elle a été
kidnappée dans son Kibo et nous sommes
aussi les cousins de Tamir Hadar il a 38
ans et deux jeunes
enfants ma sœur Tamar elle a 27 ans elle
était au festival et depuis elle a
disparu ça fait 3 semaines et 2 jours
que nous n'avons pas de nouvelle nous
n'avons aucun signe de vie aucune preuve
on ne sait pas s'ils sont morts ou dans
quelles condition ils sont retenus voilà
aujourd'hui on estime à 230 le nombre
d'otagees retenus par le Hamas Merci à
VOUS Elsa mondingava Jean-Louis
bourlange yalbron pivé évoqué ce chiffre
de neuf ressortissants français qui
seraiit aux mains aujourd'hui du du
Hamas que peut faire la France pour
aider à la libération de de ces otages
aujourd'hui la France fait je crois ce
qu'elle peut c'est-à-dire que la
première chose c'est d'avoir une
position euh équilibrée sur ce équilibré
ça veut dire évidemment favorable à la
sécurité d'Israël mais consciente de des
excès de des des bombardements et cetera
je crois que le message de la France est
un message qui peut-être reçu euh mais
le sera-t-il nous avons affaire à des
gens qui sont absolument abominables la
prise d'otage terroristes euh la prise
d'otage les des enfants enfin c'est la
pire des choses qui puisse se produire
est-ce qu'on doit négocier par
l'intermédiaire de pays comme le Qatar
je n'en sais rien mais je crois que la
responsabilité principale c'est le
gouvernement israélien le est-ce que le
gouvernement israélien doit considérer
que les otages c'est secondaire que en
réalité euh on peut passer outre et
qu'il faut
d'abord infliger des des pertes
militaires importantes au au Hamas ou
pas jusqu'à présent Israël avait
toujours été très attentif à la défense
des otages et à au souciis de elle avait
même dans des conditions impressionnante
échanger un israélien contre des
dizaines ou des centaines de de
Palestiniens donc mais apparemment le
monsieur
netanahou qui reçoit n'est pas sur cette
ligne il est sur une ligne dure moi je
comprends qu'on soit sur une ligne dure
mais je vais savoir où elle mène h je ne
vois pas où elle mène politiquement et
je vois où elle mène sur la sur les
otages donc je trouve que c'est c'est
c'est préoccupant très préoccupant et
quand je suis sûr que le président
Macron le le le le
kéorsé les les intermédiaires que nous
pouvons avoir dans le monde dans dans le
monde Palestine que ce soit l'Égypte le
roi de
Jordanie l'autorité administrative font
absolument ce qui ce qu'il peuvent pour
essayer de de de de résoudre cet
abominable problème et je voudrais quand
même dire ma profonde solidarité à
l'égard des familles j'imagine ce que ça
doit être que d'avoir aucune information
sur des des des êtres très proches on ne
sait pas où ils en sont on ne sait pas
s'ils sont en bonne santé s'ils sont
vivants on ne sait rien c'est une ang
absolument insupportable on va passer à
un autre sujet à présent avec vous
Richard verli bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
le le correspondant à Paris du média en
ligne Suisse blique vous avez choisi de
nous parler du Premier ministre hongrois
Victor Orban on l'a vu il y a de
semaines aller serrer la main à à
Vladimir Poutine c'était à Pékin lors
d'un déplacementun voyage à Pékin et il
n est pas rester là dans la foulée
Victor Orban a estimé que l'Union
européenne fonctionne je cite comme
l'Union soviétique faux lui a répondu
Emmanuel Macron lors du sommet européen
de Bruxelles que vous avez suivi oui
alors Clément on parle souvent de
désinformation de complottisme Ben pour
Victor Orban c'est beaucoup plus simple
c'est la fausse accusation l'énorme
accusation destinée bien sûr à faire
peur à sa population c'est une méthode
tout à fait soviétique donc il dit UE
Union européenne égale URSS Union
soviétique et ça de la part d'un
dirigeant qui au moment de l'écroulement
de l'URSS était un activiste libéral
tout à fait prooccidental pour qui
Moscou représentait le diable un
dirigeant don le pays la Hongrie
rappelons-le a souffert dans sa chair en
1956 lorsque les chars soviétiques sont
intervenus et un dirigeant par ailleurs
dont le pays reçoit chaque année des
dizaines de milliards d'euros de
Bruxelles sauf que là c'est un peu le
problème parce qu'en ce moment une
partie de ces fonds est bloqué en raison
de ses atteintes à l'indépendance de la
justice alors oui j'avoue ça faisait
plaisir d'entendre Emmanuel Macron lors
de la conférence de presse finale au
sommet européen remettre Victor Orban à
sa place avec un argument simple c'est
en liberté à l'issue d'une décision
souveraine que la Hongrie a intégré en
2004 l'Union européenne au côté de ne9u
autres pays c'est en liberté à l'issue
d'un vote démocratique que ce pays de 10
millions d'habitants a accepté de
déléguer un certain nombre de ses
compétences à la Commission et c'est
cette Europe libre et démocratique qui
depuis 20 ans a assuré à la Hongrie une
prospérité sans précédent et en plus de
cela Victor Orban a fait AmiAmi avec
Vladimir Poutine oui elle a aussi bien
joué pour Emmanuel Macron parce que le
président français n'a pas condamné le
déplacement en Chine de Victor Orban et
sa rencontre avec Poutine et ce pour
deux raisons la première parce que
justement les pays membres de l'UE
restent souverains la seconde parce que
maintenir le contact avec le président
russe ça peut servir Emmanuel Macron on
le sait avait longtemps tenté lui-même
de continuer de dialoguer avec le
kremelin en revanche Orban a des devoirs
à rappeler le chef de l'État devoir
d'informer ses partenaires de l'Union
européenne de ne pas affaiblir l'Union
qui dépense des milliards d'euros pour
son pays un devoir tout simplement de
respecter ce que l'Union soviétique nier
et écraser la liberté et la démocratie
Merci à VOUS Richard verli d'un mot
Jean-Louis bourlange on sait que
Vladimir Poutine aime s'engouffrer un
peu dans les brèches de ses adversaires
dans les failles est-ce que la Hongrie
on est une pour dire Richard verli est
parfait j'ajouterai j'ajouterai un fait
non seulement non seulement ils sont
rentrés librement mais ils peuvent
sortir
librement le brexit c'est pas c'est ça
ça c'est ça peut être utilisé par la
Hongrie donc véritablement c'est un
procès qui n'a aucun sens et et qu'il
est affligeant devoir devoir faire par
un dirigeant qui qui a été quand même à
un moment un très grand défenseur de la
liberté mais qui a manifestement oublié
ce moment merci Jean-Louis bourlange
Cécilia gabizon c'est à VOUS bonsoir je
rappelle que vous dirigeer la rédaction
du groupe ETX Magellan et alors vous
voulez nous parler aujourd'hui d'un
sujet beaucoup plus léger les émojis de
la discorde alors expliquez-nous quel
est le problème des emojis alors c'est
vrai que c'est un petit peu plus léger
que tout ce qui pèse en ce moment sur la
société mais c'est néanmoins très
symbolique ok commençons par le problème
l'emmoji en question l'emmoji clin d'œil
pour les plus âgés je ne situerai pas
cette ligne mais pour les plus âgés
l'émojie clin d'œil c'est un émojie de
complicité je te fais un clin d'œil et
cetera pour d'autres plus jeune et pas
tous les jeunes au contraire c'est un
emoji agressif ironique voire même on
parle de passif agressif de toxique et
notamment dans le cadre des courriers
des mails ou des messages de travail
alors qu'est-ce que ça nous raconte
cette histoire d'émojis d'interprétation
des émojis les émojis étaient fait pour
mieux se comprendre justement l'émoji
devait indiquer le contexte un cœur un
soleil c'est positif et cetera et une
grande discorde c'est en quelque sorte
focaliser sur l'émoji parce que c'est
l'émoji qui indique l'émotion or au sein
des entreprises on va dire que un
certain nombre de jeunes notamment ne se
sentent pas bien il y a pas que les
jeunes qui ont un rapport difficile au
travail mais on l'a vu là avec le
rapport sur les absences et notamment
les absences pour des problèmes de santé
mental très importants chez les jeunes
et en fait ils se sentent oppressés et
dans les messages qu'on échange dans le
langage de l'entreprise l'emmoji vient
cristalliser vient cristall is une
relation où on ne se sent pas un soupçon
une méfiance j'interprète à l'envers
alors même le pouce pour vous dire
certes il y a le CLIN d'œil mais même le
pouce mon pouce brésilien le to est mis
en cause comme un ce pouce voudrait dire
ouais cause toujours quelque chose d'un
peu expéditif et cetera donc cette
espèce de grand malentendu autour des
mojis ce que ça dit c'est qu'en fait il
y a une forme d'air du soupçon et
partout où il y a une émotion qui se
glisse le soupçon s'y installe et pour
autant je fais les questions et les
réponses car je sais qu' all V je suis
en train de VO voilà pour autant en fait
c'est en même temps ils sont ces jeunes
même demandeurs de retour et ça un
rapport avec les mojis depuis qu'ils
sont jeunes quelque part c'est les
générations internet tout ce qu'ils font
sucit des emojis succite des pouces
sucit des likes sucit des réactions le
leur vie entière est documentée sauf
dans le casre de l'entreprise ù quand
vous faites quelque chose en général on
ne vous met pas immédiatement un like un
pouce un cœur un soleil et donc il y a
une espèce de vide émotionnel autour du
travail qui explique d'ailleurs en
partie le fait que les jeunes se sentent
mal donc
emojis on se comprend pas le CLIN d'œil
attention est-ce que je l'empoie est-ce
que je l'empoie pas faut arrêter les
mojis non moi je dirais au contraire
faut renforcer les émojis faut se
commenter mais faut aussi se donner le
bénéfice du doute positif quand je ne
suis pas sûr du sens d'un émojis allons
vers le doute positif merci beaucoup
jean-l bourgean je agrég de lettre que
vous êtes vous utilisez les émojis vous
dans j'utilise pas les émojis je
découvre ce ce phénomène avec beaucoup
d' je crois qu'il faut s'y intéresser
effectivement bon merci beaucoup
bourlange d'avoir été notre grand témoin
ce soir merci à à tous les trois nos
affranchis ça vous regarde reprend jeudi
avec myiam enkawa passer une bonne
soirée sur
[Musique]
LCP